thank you jillian all right flora
couture is here to help us bloom into
2022 let's welcome founder and creative
director of this beautiful local shop i
love it there michelle joy howard we are
talking holiday florals of course
because it is that time
i know you are busy very
so how do we how do we take our holiday
florals and then the trick is transition
them into new year's right
so for example like a garland like this
yes music very classic and whether you
put something like this down your table
for your beautiful holiday dinner right
then you bring a floral into it and then
if you want to like decorate it up a
little bit more you add some color into
it okay so i got some things for you
right here we love props so i'm gonna
have you you know find a spot where
they're perfect to add in here we go
these are my
these are my merry christmas
decorations right placement is
everything right so how do you so you
want to how do you do proper placement
right so you see how we've got several
things clustered in so you want to
cluster them in you want your ribbon to
kind of come in between them slow down
the entire piece so how'd i do with that
you did great with that okay so now find
me another spot for that one and i'm
thinking this one should go
like right behind here
so and then what we do is we have
chenilles on them so we actually tie
them in so nothing's going to fall off
nothing's going to move it's not just a
little tiny hook it's really secure in
there it's not going anywhere i love
that and you can get more creative than
that you can add other elements like
i've given you some other things there
like if you want to add more you can
take glittery fun stuff oh my gosh but
we talked about transitioning right now
you have all of this at your shop
remember my my floral elves are all over
this town decorated that's right so
would that make you mrs claus
well i guess maybe just like master
outlaw okay
how am i doing here okay placement so
things like this we want to actually
kind of slide
that was a trick so exactly so and you
don't even have to hook these in because
they're right in there for good now but
we talked about transitioning
for new year's right let's do that so
maybe we want to transition out of red
right pull the red out the gold can stay
there right
in so i think you've got a couple gold
ornaments over there so you add those in
my new year
this is so this is brilliant okay i love
this idea
and then as we go into the new year of
course i'm thinking valentine's day is
coming up too it comes before you know
we're tearing down christmas and we're
there right exactly so before we get to
that talk you know these flowers the
flowers on trend right now for the
season what do people need
they need flowers everywhere
but there's well so what you see in
front of you here we have peonies
they're in season right now we have
amaryllis over here very seasonal to
this time of year perfect christmas
flowers exactly um but your reds your
whites your silvers your golds you'll
see a lot of the traditional stuff like
if you go to our website we've got
beautiful traditional whites if you're
just wanting to stay very neutral very
clean right or you go into the beautiful
red colorations i love it to each his
own you can have there's so much
creativity so what's your website really
quick
www.floracouture.com there you go thank
you master elf awesome to you jillian